inventer les vaccins avec pasteur dont
la réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir avec comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
j'ai mangé avant le début de la
vaccination grand public en france et à
partir de demain les plus de 75 ans vont
pouvoir recevoir la première injection
antique vide
le temps presse alors que les variants
du commun d'un virus préoccupe un cas de
la souche sud-africaine a été détecté à
la réunion un autre du même type a été
confirmée à mayotte une poussée de
l'épidémie est probable en mars alerte
l'épidémiologie tanoh fontanes et membre
du conseil scientifique washington en
état d' alerte à trois jours de la
cérémonie d'investiture de joe biden la
ville se barricade dans la crainte de
nouvelles violences aux abords du
capitole le président élu il se prépare
à sa prise de fonction changement
climatique pandémie crise économique
injustices raciales et sociales shs
weiden promet une série de décrets dès
mercredi au premier jour de sa
présidence
[Musique]
alexeï navalni arrêté par la police
l'opposant russe a été interpellée à son
arrivée à l'aéroport de moscou phr les
services pénitentiaires lui reproche
d'avoir violé les conditions d'une peine
de prison avec sursis dont il a écopé en
il restera en détention jusqu'à la
décision du tribunal annonce ces mêmes
autorités
alexeï navalni en provenance de berlin
où il se remettait depuis plusieurs mois
d'un empoisonnement présumés
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les variants
ducobu 19 les styles présager des temps
encore plus difficiles ces prochains
mois c'est en tout cas l'inquiétude de
l'épidémiologiste arnaud fontanet membre
du conseil scientifique qui accompagne
le gouvernement ils alertent sur une
possible progression de l'épidémie dès
le mois de mars alors qu'un nouveau cas
du var ion sud africain a été détecté à
la réunion qui hier un autre du même
type a été confirmée cette fois ci à
mayotte
dans ce contexte la campagne de
vaccination est source d'espoir et
s'ouvre au grand public ce lundi
les plus de 75 ans pourront d'autre
recevoir la première injection antique
vide 1 dès demain lé français est
favorable au principe d'un passeport
vaccinale selon un sondage ifop réalisé
pour le parisien ce dimanche près de 6
français interrogés sur 10 ne serait pas
contre l'idée d'une vaccination
obligatoire pour prendre un avion à
destination l'étranger ou encore pour
rendre visite à une personne vulnérable
dans un ehpad ou un hôpital
une position défendue ces derniers jours
par la grèce mais qui divise les 27 pays
de l'ue de son côté l'om s6 déclaré a
opposé pour le moment pour le
gouvernement français le débat n'est pas
d'actualité
nous sommes très réticents si on parle
d'un papier un document qui vous
autorise à voyager en europe je crois
que c'est très prématuré
ce n'est pas notre conception de la
protection et de l'accès au vaccin
c'est une idée sur laquelle la france
considère qu'on ne doit pas ouvrir le
débat maintenant quand l'accès au vaccin
sera généralisé ce sera un sujet
différent à l'ensemble de l'hexagone
désormais sous couvre-feu chaque jour
dès 18 heures la mesure est entrée en
vigueur hier pas tout le temps bien
respectée far 1900 verbalisation
auraient ainsi été adressée ce samedi
couvre-feu pour le moment car premier
ministre n'a pas exclu le recours au
confinement en cas d'aggravation de la
situation sanitaire walid ben ali
il désigne les présidences mon fils de
florencio les forces de l'ordre sur le
qui vive dans une rue parisienne
habituellement peuple et ses mesures de
couvre-feu existait déjà il débutait à
20 heures il a été avancé de deux heures
mais là aussi la population est
désormais l'habitude de ces mesures
donc la tolérance est bien moindre et si
des infractions sont constatées elles
seront relevés et verbaliser une
situation devenue presque normal se
confiner une nouvelle fois pour mieux
résister au virus
mais cette fois pas question de sortir
après sa journée de travail
personnellement je pense que la majorité
des gens vont faire leurs courses vont
faire les achats entre guillemets qui
leur sont essentiels à ces heures là le
problème c'est que ce couvre-feu en fait
qui passe de 20 heures à 18 heures va
énormément favoriser le télétravail est
pour moi qui adore me rendre sur mon
lieu de travail bien je serai on va dire
force et je pense que pour beaucoup de
gens ça va rentrer chez eux et puis
après la vie s'arrête un peu et
lendemain on repart au boulot 21h20
heure 18 heures depuis trois mois le
gouvernement serre la vis en espérant
juguler une situation sanitaire
compliqué la france n'arrive pas à
atteindre son objectif passer sous la
barre des 5000 contamination par jour
depuis le début de l'année 2021 il est
question de vingt mille nouveaux cas
journaliers en moyenne des français ces
petits aujourd'hui face au succès du
couvre-feu
parce que si on va rentrer chez nous
avant 18 heures ma les gens ils vont ils
vont se concentrer dans le métro dans
les bus ça va rien changer du tout c'est
vrai que les gens se rassemblent un peu
entre 18 et 20 heures en sortant du
travail du coup je pense que ce sera un
petit impact mais c'est vrai qu'on voit
le monde ici on sait pas trop où on se
pose des questions
et pourtant face au virus et à ces
variants anglais sud africain le
couvre-feu semble avoir son efficacité
pour le premier ministre est selon la
communauté scientifique dans les 15
premiers départements où le couvre feu a
été mis en oeuvre
18 heures le 2 janvier dernier la hausse
du nombre de nouveaux cas y ait deux
voire trois fois plus faible que dans
les autres départements métropolitains
très clairement les données des tests et
les données hospitalières sont en faveur
d'un impact de ces premiers couvre-feu
l'évolution des indicateurs a fortement
ralenti et les courbes ont ensuite chuté
un couvre-feu avancée qui questionne
d'autant plus que le gouvernement a
prévenu cette semaine
le pire serait encore à venir leur
confinement reste une option sur la
table si la situation devait se dégrader
fortement
nous verrons dans les jours les semaines
qui viennent si la circulation du virus
est contenue
si cela ne suffit pas il y aura un
confinement les français pourront
toujours se déplacer entre 18h et 6h du
matin pour motifs professionnels
familiaux ou encore judiciaire dûment
muni d'une attestation sous peine d'une
amende inchangé de 135 euros
à noter également que cinq communes de
guyane sont toujours concernés par le
couvre feu
ce dernier passant de 21 heures à 19
heures plus d'un millier de personnes
5000 selon les organisateurs rassemblés
cet après midi place du trocadéro à
paris pour une marche pour la vie a en
effet organisé tous les ans contre
l'avortement cette année les
protestataires dénonçaient deux projets
de loi en particulier la loi bioéthique
qui comprend notamment à la pma pour
toutes les femmes ainsi que la
proposition de loi qu'il porte le délai
pour avorter de douze à quatorze
semaines de textes qui seront examinée
la semaine prochaine au sénat
notre reporter david khalifa a suivi ce
rassemblement cet après midi un
rassemblement statique à cause des
restrictions sanitaires pour cette 13e
édition de la marche de la vie à une
forte mobilisation cet après midi ici
place du trocadéro plus de 3000
personnes selon lé organisateurs avec un
objectif clair protester contre le
projet de loi bioéthique et
l'allongement délibérée de douze à
quatorze semaines de texte est examiné
par le sénat cette semaine
l'avortement considéré comme un enjeu de
santé publique pour la plupart des
manifestants
présents ici une originalité aussi à
signaler c'est que ceux qui n'ont pas pu
se déplacer ont pu suivre ce
rassemblement via l'application zoom
afin de soutenir le mouvement
en tout cas le la marche pour la vie
souhaite la mise en place d'une
politique de prévention pour réduire
leurs coûts rallye vg je vous propose
d'écouter quelques manifestants présents
ici c'était important pour moi d'être là
pour mettre pour envoyer un signal au
gouvernement pour qu'il mette enfin
entre guillemets qui met le un petit
stop sur les réformes qui viennent
menacer la famille que ce soit dans la
conception de menacer la famille pardon
menacer la vie et que ça soit sa
conception jusqu'à sa jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie à la fin de la ville avec les
potentiels mans les lois de bioéthique
mais on espère vraiment que le le
gouvenement qu'elle va faire marche
arrière et que avoir su rendre compte
que la vie est plus importante que c'est
un combat qui a amené et que vraiment
c'est peut-être pas le moment
d'abord que c'est pas vraiment de mener
ces temps de changer la loi parce qu'il
ya d'autres préoccupations et dans tous
les cas je pense que la loi n'est pas
forcément très bonnes amies on doit
laisser la possibilité aux gens de
pouvoir choisir et l'allongement du
délai n'est vraiment pas une bonne chose
la défense de la vie c'est vraiment le
droit fondamental
on nous parle beaucoup des droits de
l'homme mais le premier droit c'est le
droit à la vie et ce droit ils se
discute pas il est absolu si on commence
à décider qui peut vivre qui ne peut pas
vivre
aucun droit ne peut tenir donc c'est
vraiment le fondement de toute la
civilisation et spécialement la
civilisation chrétienne
c'est vraiment là dessus qu'il faut se
battre selon les chiffres en 2019 on
recense près de 230 de 1000 avortements
un record dans l'hexagone les
associations présentes et icipe
souhaitent des alternatifs pour
accompagner les futures mères en
difficulté et des aides sociales plus
nombreuses en tout cas ce rassemblement
s'est déroulé de manière assez festive
et musicale puisque plusieurs concerts
se sont succédé ici sur la scène place
du trocadéro et les intervenants
également se sont succédé sur la scène
afin de prévenir des dangers sur la
santé mentale vis-à-vis des femmes qui
ont recours à l'avortement
et on part maintenant au brésil débordé
par la pandémie
le pays a dépassé la semaine dernière la
barre des 200 mille victimes du coville
19 au nord l'état d'amazonas a annoncé
jeudi l'instauration d'un couvre feu de
dix jours dans la ville de manaus la
situation est critique
les malades ne cessent d'affluer les
hôpitaux font déborder et manque
d'oxygène le récit d'amaya soubelet les
hôpitaux de manos arrive à saturation et
toujours pas d'oxygène à l'horizon pour
les personnels soignants
depuis plusieurs semaines l'état de
l'amazonas connaît d'importantes
pénuries d'équipements qui force les
habitants à s'approvisionner auprès
d'entreprises privées voire du marché
noir afin de tenter de sauver leurs
proches
je ne veux pas perdre et c'est tellement
triste ce que nous voyons nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation si
difficile dans nine tron une image du
monde à l'agonie en raison d'un manque
d'oxygène
nous avons besoin de personnes plus
compétentes qui serait lorsqu'elle
constate un manque d'oxygène faire
quelque chose pour y remédier les
hôpitaux sont bondés
nous traitons les patients à domicile
ils mourront chez eux gouverneur s'il
vous plaît laissez nous acheter de
l'oxygène
la seule usine et celle ci le nombre
d'entrées à l'hôpital a explosé sur la
première partie du mois de janvier
depuis le début de l'année 1979
personnes ont été admises à cause du coc
vide 19
un chiffre déjà supérieur à celui du
mois de mai lors de la première vague
alors que certains habitants doivent
apporter leur propre bouteille d'oxygène
à l'hôpital les médecins en sont réduits
à ventiler manuellement les malades
pour tenter de pallier les carences
actuelles vendredi l'armée a délivré des
bonbonnes d'oxygène à manos de nombreux
patients ont été transférés dans
d'autres états du pays afin d'alléger
les hôpitaux de la ville
dans le même temps les brésiliens ont
fait part de leur indignation face à la
situation sanitaire appelant depuis
leurs fenêtres à la démission du
président jean pierre bel subaru
depuis jeudi un couvre-feu a été
instauré de 19h à 6h du matin pour dix
jours afin de ralentir l'épidémie touché
de plein fouet par la deuxième vague
le brésil doit commencer sa campagne de
vaccination le 20 janvier
si les demandes d'autorisation d'urgence
sont acceptés une situation à laquelle
vient s'ajouter une source d'inquiétude
supplémentaire pour les autorités
sanitaires la découverte au japon
d'invariants brésilien du coronavirus en
argentine la deuxième cargaison du
vaccin russe poutine gates arrivé hier à
buenos aires 300 mille doses en
provenance de moscou est destiné aux
membres du personnel soignant qui ont
déjà reçu une première dose il ya
plusieurs semaines
l'argentine a été le premier pays
d'amérique latine a enregistré
officiellement spoutnik vrai qu'en
contres locaux vides elle recevra encore
5 millions de doses en janvier puis 14,7
autres millions ont février à l'orgue
est un bon point compte encore de la
vérité c'est que nous sommes très
heureux de faire partie de ce processus
est assez limité valeur d'abord afin de
surmonter ce virus qui combine tournoi à
trois jours de son investiture joe biden
promet une série de décrets dès son
entrée en fonction le président
américain élu s'est engagé à en signer
un certains nombres premiers jours de sa
présidence
ce qui lui évitera d'en passer par le
congrès qui pourraient devoir se
consacrer à la procédure de destitution
de donald trump sont concernés par ces
décrets le changement climatique la
pandémie la crise économique les
injustices raciales et sociales au temps
de crise qui nécessite une action
d'urgence selon son futur chef de
cabinet
la transition se déroulera donc un
mercredi prochain washington s'y prépare
la capitale fédérale
placées en état d' alerte nos amis via
barrière de béton clôture points de
contrôle ambiance tendue à washington
plus de 21 mille soldats de la garde
nationale ont été déployés dans la
capitale le 6 janvier dernier le
capitole a été pris d'assaut par les
partisans du président sortant
les troubles qui ont fait cinq victimes
dont un agent de police
une violence qui a choqué l'amérique et
le monde et que donald trump mis en
cause par ses adversaires politiques a
fini par condamner
que vous soyez de droite ou de gauche
démocrates ou républicains il n'y a
jamais de justification à la violence
pas d'excusés pas d'exception
l'amérique est une nation de loi à ceux
qui ont participé aux attaques de la
semaine dernière seront poursuivis en
justice
les enquêteurs du fbi se disent inquiets
après l'interception de plusieurs
messages selon eux un projet d' attaques
contre le capitole à washington mais
aussi contre chaque capitole des 50
états seraient en préparation des
attaques armées qui débuterait ce
dimanche et qui pourrait culminer le 20
janvier jour de l'investiture de joe
biden depuis le 6 janvier le fbi a
arrêté une centaine de personnes parmi
elles des figures connues pour leur
engagement dans des mouvements
complotistes des suprémacistes blancs ou
encore des extrémistes voire ce voyou
avec cette chemise et son antisémitisme
dont il s'est vanté faire partie d'un
raid de la suprématie blanche contre ce
capitole nous oblige à faire un bilan
des actes et a attribué la
responsabilité à ceux qui ont participé
à son organisation et à son incitation
suite à ce coup de force la chef des
démocrates à la chambre des
représentants a appelé à des maîtres
donald trump de ses fonctions mercredi
10 représentants républicains se sont
joints aux votes de mise en accusation
du président sortant pour la capitale
fédérale 1 barricades et tu jamais vu
pour ses habitants
c'est vraiment effrayant on est inquiet
non seulement pour le capitole et les
bâtiments la maison blanche
mais pour les quartiers résidentiels
parce qu'on vit très très près d'ici on
a des amis qui habitent à capitol hill
et de voir que nos quartiers sont
confinés c'est vraiment effrayant
on dirait une ville fantôme c'est
vraiment étrange
la dernière fois qu'on était ici il ya
une semaine il y avait plein de voitures
c'est une avenue très fréquentée c'est
très bizarre
on dirait une ville fantôme je suis
content de voir la présence des forces
de l'ordre mais dans un coin de votre
tête vous savez pourquoi ils sont là et
c'est un peu stressant et c'est de ce
vent que la ville était est tout
retourné à cause de ce qui s'est passé
la semaine dernière
c'est déconcertant mais je le comprends
ils n'incluent près tous des terroristes
américains ont tenté de créer des
problèmes dans le pays entre guillemets
de la liberté est donc pour moi c'est
ahurissant mais il fallait le faire pour
que l'investiture se passe bien
alexeï navalni restera en détention
jusqu'à la décision du tribunal sur son
cas c'est ce que déclare ce soir les
services pénitentiaires russes
ils ont arrêté l'opposant alors qu'il
s'apprêtait à passer le contrôle des
postes des passeports à son arrivée à
l'aéroport sheremetyevo de moscou tout à
l'heure il lui reproche d'avoir violé
les conditions d'une peine de prison
avec sursis dont il a écopé en 2014
alexeï navalni de retour d'allemagne où
il était en convalescence depuis cinq
mois après un empoisonnement présumés on
retrouve notre correspondant à moscou
antoine clairon bonsoir antoine
racontez-nous ces dernières heures de ce
retour d'alexis navalni en russie
[Musique]
antoine claireaux est ce que vous êtes
avec nous vous avez suivi tout cet
après-midi l'arrivée d'alexis navalni en
russie est ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ces derniers événements ces
dernières heures
oui bah ces dernières heures dans un
premier temps il devait atterrir à
l'aéroport de vnoukovo où je me trouve
actuellement mais au dernier moment
alors que l'avion survolait la région il
a finalement été détournés vers
l'aéroport de cheremetievo et finalement
c'est à sheremetyevo que l'avion a
atterri
l'avion a atterri là pu en sortir de
façon libre enfin de sortir de la bulle
même accordé une courte interview aux
journalistes qui l'accompagnaient à bord
de l'avion une fois arrivé dans le
terminal
et c'est au moment de passer le contrôle
des passeports le contrôle de sécurité
qu'il a finalement été arrêté par les
autorités alors vous l'avez évoqué la
raison invoquée par la police c'est bien
une violation de sa période de probation
il est en effet jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 sous le coup d'une période
probatoire dans la sphère dans le cadre
d'une affaire de détournement de fonds
un tribunal qui a rendu un jugement une
condamnation de plusieurs années de
prison avec sursis
pour alexeï navalni et voilà il est
temps en allemagne il n'a pu répondre
aux obligations de cette paire de cette
période de probation et c'est donc pour
cette raison qu'il a été arrêté
quasiment dès son arrivée dès sa
descente de l'avion ici à moscou
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux alexeï
navalni présenté comme l'opposant
principal à vladimir poutine mais de
quel soutien populaire bénéficie-t-il
vraiment quelle est sa place dans le
paysage politique russe nous avons posé
ces questions à karim b chez golovkov
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou
difficile quand même pour jeu pour lui
de jouer les martyrs ce n'est pas
vraiment le retour de soljenitsyne que
nous sommes en train de voir sur les
vidéos qui sont diffusées quelques
centaines de personnes
dans l'ensemble qui l'attendent à vous
dans l'ensemble ce sont quand même ses
partisans donc sont des gens qui
travaillent pour lui sont des gens donc
qui sont payés pour ça donc on peut pas
parler d'un soutien populaire massif
envers ce que l'occident s'acharne a
appelé l'opposant n'eut
moi concrètement il faut quand même pas
oublier que une avanie n'a pas été
condamné pour ses prises de position
politiques
il a été condamné pour des malversations
pour de l'escroquerie que son frère lui
en revanche qu'ils n'étaient pas aussi
médiatisée a réellement exécuté sa peine
de prison à la différence d alex est née
vanille qui a parfaitement bénéficier de
de sa réputation médiatique et ça n'a
absolument pas du tout dérangé en
ouganda le parti de bobby brown demande
sa libération immédiate et
inconditionnelle
le leader de l'opposition reste assigné
à résidence au lendemain de l'annoncé
des résultats a contesté l'élection
présidentielle le président sortant
yoweri museveni a été reconduit pour un
sixième mandat avec 58,6 % des voix
derrière lui avec 34 8% des suffrages
bobby one qui estiment que le scrutin a
été entaché de fraudes fils assure qu'il
est assiégée par les soldats et la
police qui ont encerclé sa maison
empêchant quiconque d'entrer ou de
sortir vous propose d'écouter le vice
président de la plate forme de l'unité
nationale le parti de body one
[Musique]
we demand nous exigeons la libération
immédiate et inconditionnelle de notre
chef et cette déclaration immédiate en
tant que président de la république
dûment élu car nous savons qu'il a gagné
[Applaudissements]
nous exigeons également la libération
immédiate de tous les membres et les
dirigeants du nuc détenus au secret dans
divers centres de détention du pays pour
leur permettre de retrouver leur famille
ou de les faire inculper s'ils ont
commis d'infraction et pour lui que
mayouf président du club de
l'information africaine la manipulation
du scrutin ne fait aucun doute qu'on
voit une main de violence dans lequel
s'est déroulé et surtout sur des petits
de erin quand on organise léger sur le
sait qu'on voit à peu près à qui profite
le crime et on voit à peu près que c'est
le même mécanisme est mis en place
lorsque les pouvoirs ne sont pas
certains de remporter des élections
on a entendu que les observateurs
électoraux qui se plaignaient de n'avoir
pas vu la capacité de transmettre les
élections de transmettre le résultat de
vérifier dans quelles conditions
tout cela était organisé et transmis
maintenant reste à savoir quelle est
l'ampleur de cette robe est ce qu'elle
est de nature à changer le sens du vote
populaire
la question est là dès 8 ans que ce ne
sont pas des élections donc on pourrait
certifié aujourd'hui le corps dit cité
et dans quelle forme ils parlent
l'expression du peuple ou en
centrafrique situation sécuritaire
toujours très tendue après un ultimatum
lancé aux rebelles à par l'onu les
casques bleus ont repris le contrôle de
la ville a de bons gars saoul aller
située à 750 km à l'est de bangui la
capitale
elle était occupée depuis le début du
mois par des groupes armés qui ont lancé
une offensive contre le président réélu
faustin archange touadéra réaction du
porte-parole de la minustah en
centrafrique
la ville de bangassou est sous contrôle
total de la mine jusqu'à suite à
l'ultimatum lancé vendredi par la force
de la mission au groupe armé les
rebelles ont abandonné les positions
qu'ils occupaient et fuient la ville
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi et
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale
en bref et en images en afghanistan deux
femmes jeu travaillons pour la cour
suprême ont été tués par balles à kaboul
ce dimanche
le meurtre n'a pas été revendiqué mais
le président afghan accusé les talibans
la taxe est déroulée quelques heures
après une réunion entre la délégation
talibans l'envoyé spécial de washington
sur le conflit et le commandant des
forces américaines dans le pays
l'organiste ont été le théâtre ces
derniers mois d'une série d'assassinats
ciblés de personnalités dont des membres
des médias hommes politiques et
défenseurs des droits humains
plus de 80 morts dans des affrontements
entre tribus rivales au darfour cette
région de l'ouest du soudan qui connaît
une recrudescence de violences tribales
ces derniers événements interviennent
deux semaines après la fin d'une mission
de paix au darfour
[Musique]
l armée nigériane a repris ce matin le
contrôle de la base militaire de marthe
située dans le nord-est du pays
elle était est aux mains des combattants
d'une branche dissidente du groupe
djihadiste est de boko haram combattants
qui avaient attaqué cette base
stratégique vendredi soir il en avait
toujours le contrôle hier dans la
journée avant finalement d'en être
délogés par l'armée nigériane et
notamment par une lourde opération
aérienne et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]